[Music]
alex
is with us in seattle washington hi alex
how are you
hey dave doing okay okay
uh i guess don't be mad but um
so i sold my house and i used the money
to fly through the baby steps
and i'm kind of worried because i used
it also to
get through my emergency fund and i had
enough to cover
percentage payment on a new house it
just feels kind of dirty like
i'm borrowing borrowing against my house
right now i'm not mad it's exactly what
i
told you to do really yeah i would tell
you not to buy a house unless you were
debt-free and had your emergency fund so
if you cash out of house number one
the first thing you can do is clear your
debt put your emergency fund in place
and whatever's left over is your down
payment on your new house
you're right the net effect is as you
did borrow it against the new house
but that's still what i would have told
you to do and as long as the new house
is 15-year fixed and the payment's no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
we're on the same page here it is can i
ask a second question
sure the new house was appraised
at 15 000 under the uh
the listing value and i can't tell if
i'm
getting a good deal or if i'm about to
get hosed
did you close on it uh
i'm super close to that happening okay
all right i thought you had already
bought it the way you're talking a
minute ago
okay so i mean so what's the price of
the house
uh well it appraised that's
at 323 your my buying price was
originally gonna be 332.
okay uh so let's see if
it is four percent
uh that was quick an appraisal is
an opinion of value
i dare say in today's coveted world that
an appraiser can hit it within four
percent
it's a little bit arrogant of the
appraiser honestly to not appraise it
for contact
contract value when it's within that
area
but some appraisers think they're barney
fife and they like actually know the
real value
it's an opinion of value based on a
comparative
market analysis approach i've got a
degree in real estate
i know how to do appraisals so i i
argue with appraisers all the time they
really act like well i have this figured
out is
it's you know i had a guy arguing with
me over 500 bucks one time
you know it's a 242 five or 242 thousand
like you know within 500 bucks what this
house is worth you're an idiot this is
me and the appraiser
yelling at him it's just ridiculous so
uh
i would buy the house no you're not
getting hosed if you call me up you go
you're 35
over or something yeah you might be
getting hosed your emotions may have got
the best of you but i don't think
anybody knows within four percent
in a coveted world what a house is worth
i don't
and i'm good at it so i think you're
fine dude i think you're in good shape
because i tell you can real estate
selling like crazy copper's up 34
so wiring going into houses is crazy you
can't buy plywood anywhere in the united
states
lumber packages are up 126
on new construction you can't find
asphalt shingles to put on a house the
factories aren't producing
the goods to build the new houses and
guess what that's doing to the used
housing market
hot hot hot hot going to drive prices up
because supply demand curve is there
unless you live in one of these states
where they're completely abandoning the
entire state like california
and even then i heard talked to a guy
from san diego last night
who told me that it makes no sense
people are leaving california by the
droves and yet the house price the
houses are selling 10 days
for full price still some prices have
not taken a hit yet
and and for the for the folks that are
listening dave that have never bought a
home
and correct me if i'm wrong but the
appraisal um
in this situation that's for the loan
that's for the where he's getting loan
they want to make sure that they're not
giving a loan to something
that that that doesn't have the value so
it's not it's not complex
i don't know if the word is compensatory
or whatever but it's it
it's just so that the loan company the
mortgage company goes okay this is
something if something were default
we've got ourselves value isn't that
really what that appraisal is about yeah
it's an opinion of value to let the
mortgage company know that they're not
overloading on it right
and let you know let you know you're not
overpaying right
exactly and but it's an estimate for
god's sake right and the mortgage
company doesn't mind
in that situation as long as it's on the
up and up and you don't do it behind the
scenes you know behind the scenes is
illegal in some states
right so you have to cover the cash at
the closing and they're only going to
make the loan based on the
appraisal not based on the sale price
exactly and
so the loan is a different situation but
he's got a huge down payment
yeah is what we're hearing yeah behind
the scenes on this
and so he's got plenty of wiggle room
and
an extra 15k is not that big a deal on a
325 000
deal uh i wouldn't think anything about
it one way or the other
and if you bought it for 15k under that
you wouldn't think you stole it
no you bought if you buy it for 50 grand
under that under 300 000 price you think
you stole it you think you got a great
buy
right but i mean 15k was just that was
just negotiation one way or the other
you know you really don't the ratio to
the price is what
into the value is what would tell you
whether you're getting hosed or whether
you stole something or
all those kinds of things what are those
percentages yeah and
that that's what he's looking at so some
of you are in markets like we're in here
in our county
uh you put a sign in the yard and
there's like people lined up
and drawing lotto tickets to get to make
offers
and they're making multiple offers over
multiple
multiple i mean sometimes 10 20 percent
over
what it knows what it's listed for what
over asking in order to get to the front
of the line
because seven offers will come in the
first weekend that kind of stuff
and so you really need like one of our
good elps our endorsed local providers
for real estate to guide you through
basically what is effectively a bidding
war and for you to do that uh ethically
legally and also then get the most out
of the
situation because you have this frenzy
this feeding frenzy of piranha
and you want to just be careful what
you're throwing to the piranha
and because there's real opportunity in
a market like that to do well
but also to not maximize that and really
get a bunch of people sideways whether
you end up in a lawsuit or something
else because it wasn't handled right
because you did not have a pro in your
corner so you need a pro in your corner
when the market's hot
because it's hot and you need a pro in
your corner when the market's not
because it's not yeah and that's how you
get it sold it's going to ask you from a
real estate perspective
with the uh obviously still historically
low interest rates
it doesn't seem like the fed's tipping
their hand and and that we're going to
see any kind of
uh a spike anytime soon with the
migration out of california
at some point does that real estate
market begin to soften
it has to yeah it can't keep it up when
people out
even right supply demand curve well and
so you could have prices
dropping in new york as well you know
there there's a
all this discussion as to whether
manhattan will ever recover
you know because basically a science
fiction ghost town right and so will it
economically ever come back well that's
what i wanted to ask you your opinion
so let's let me tell you what will
happen this is when you this is one of
the few times that politics actually
does matter
you know we always say what happens in
your house is more important what
happens in the white house and that's
true
but when you take a government and they
shut down an entire state or an entire
city and turned into a science fiction
movie then
uh you know then you've got policies you
have to change politicians
and open the place back up and put some
common sense
policies in instead of taking credit for
being the world's best governor
when uh you know all you did was you
know the worst possible job in the whole
thing right and so it's it's not
politics it's not what it's about
it's about freedom because business
cannot operate
in two situations business cannot
operate and economics cannot flourish
unless there's freedom
and it cannot operate and flourish
unless there is a predictable moral code
and so we've had two things slam
businesses shut uh you know
downtown seattle downtown minneapolis
downtown portland
businesses are leaving because they
don't have a predictable moral code
law and order order as opposed to chaos
law as opposed to lawlessness and so
business has to have a predictable
environment we had a smart conference
schedule downtown minneapolis
i can't do a smart conference there
because i can't predict
that my people that i invite there's my
guests are not going to get into some
kind of sideways disastrous mess up
there
because the way they're managing the
city and so you lose the economics when
you don't have
a predictable moral code and you
don't have freedom to operate and so
these cities are going to suffer from
this and
that is driven by policy and the way you
change policies you change those
politicians they should be changed
regularly like diapers and for the same
reasons
this is the dave ramsey show